um what I loved about you was you were
tapping in with the West Coast yeah with
a record like walk through yeah shout
out to problems they set out a problem
man and they like uh with problems just
showed me new ways though because I
never thought like I could get on the
west coast type beat 92 bpms you know
what I'm saying La record that just
ended up going crazy everywhere shout
out yeah shout out to Dupree the
producer who made the priest a great guy
yeah man still work with him to this day
and it's just like man
um even with YG just like with mustard
like I remember first meeting them in
the studio Patchwork even we did both of
them same songs in the same Studio
different already yeah it's crazy
because you know what's Wild is like a
record like my hitter yeah
YG was having so many um he was having
problems breaking through outside of La
yeah and then he got the Rich Homie Quan
stimulus package but but like even like
to that story it is like yeah that story
like was crazy though like because even
like when I went to the studio I didn't
know who YG was like uh social media
wasn't like wasn't as popular as it is
now correct yeah so it wasn't like fly
called me and fly being t.i.g uh CEO
like man go to the studio this West
Coast artists uh on YG I want you to
know what it was easy yeah uh it was the
sign of Def Jam but Jeezy was just you
know watching them so I was like [ __ ] I
thought it was easy I'm gonna go down
food so I go to the studio man when
they're in the B room they got the B
room renting out and when I first go in
muscles on the computer but I'm thinking
muster is YG you know you see the Apple
computer nine times it ain't playing
stuff from his computer right like
watching what's up like this how I
approach it
so most of going through beats and when
he played the beat for the My Hitta all
I could think of was I mean we ain't
going in on the sample to this something
like this and Wayne was a big
inspiration to me and I was like man if
I could put my little twist on it it
would be hard
I went in there did my part
um and I left two weeks later before I
call back Jesus went on the record
his voice was messed up or something so
he couldn't do his birthday so I just
did the verse I did the hood the verse I
just left that's crazy yeah classic
classic banger